To Understand the Types of Angles We Need to Understand Just
One Simple Diagram
Consider a Ray o A We Know That If This Ray is
Rotated Completely Once It Covers 360 Degrees
All the Different Angles Which Lie in Between
0 and 360 Degrees Are Classified into
Types There  Are Two Kinds of Important
Angles We Come Across Very Often in
Mathematics The First Kind is an Angle
Like This and It Covers 1/4 of the 360
Degree Rotation Let's Call This Ray
O This Angle Formed Here is Called a Right
Angle and Since It Covers  1/4 of the
360° It measures
90° This angle is special in many ways It is
the only angle which is not marked with a curve Normally
angles are marked like this
with a curve between its two arms but a
right angle is marked like  With this
mark we don't even need to write the measure next to
it since these two lines are enough to tell you that it is a right angle and when the
angle between two rays and lines is 90° we
say they are perpendicular to each other  The next
important kind of angle you'll see often
is called the straight angle the name says it
all the arm is rotated in true a way that a
straight line is formed like this let this
arm be called
oea.sun These two angles divide the plane
into  Three Reasons Let Me Color Them For You
This Blue Region Which Is Between 0 And
90° This Yellow Region Which Is Between 90°
And
180° And This Is Between
180° And
360° We Classify The Angles Poorly Based
On These Three Reasons
To Classify  The angles in this figure we will
consider the isal arm for the angles Any angle
in the blue region
is called an acute angle Let's have another ray
Arm between 0
and 90 degrees can be called an obtuse angle that means any
angle
which has its major angle between
90 and
180° is called an obtuse angle and any angle with its terminal
arm in this red
region is called a reflex angle so if you have ray o like this then this
anta angle
starting from ray o a will be a
reflex angle so a  Reflex angle will always be greater
than
180° but less than 360 degree and if we have more than this
big angle to wood would be a
reflex angle it's very simple any
angle between 0 and 90 degree will be acute if it's between
90 and  180 degree it will be two and if it is between
degree and 360 degree it will be reflex
one way in which you can remember this
is by knowing that the letters AO and R are
in alphabetical
order this recording from math
open.com will help us  Understand Better If
the terminal arm lies anywhere between 0 and
90 degrees it will become a
right angle these are
to raise r  Said to be perpendicular to each
other anyway between 90 and 180 degrees it will be
called an angle you can see that a
wide range of angles are covered between 90
and 180 degrees and the angle is still
optus and at 180 degrees we get a straight
line and a straight angle anywhere between 180
degree and 360 degree it will be a
reflex angle any terminal arm in this anterior
region will result in a reflex angle
and 360 degree complete one full rotation and it will be called
a full
[music]
angle i